[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полтавщина,
Крячківка]
♪ [грає на торбані ритмічну музику] ♪
Це такі вправи, щоб пальці слухались.
[Юрко Фединський
Кобзар]
Одразу пальці не слухаються.
Тим паче тут такий холод.
І для торбана треба дуже слухняні пальці.
Тут є різні прийоми, як на бандурі.
Тут струни дуже близько одна до одної.
Я ще не так добре володію.
А тут на гриф [тиснеш].
♪ [грає на торбані ритмічну музику] ♪
Я зрозумів, що бідні люди
насправді мають певну перевагу.
Хоч і сучасний світ каже:
«Ні, бідна людина – це дурна. Не потрібна».
Треба бути багатим —
тоді ти успішний і щось зробив.
Але бути успішним без грошей –
це такі добрі відчуття.
Що нічого, ніякі мізерні гроші або
якийсь комфорт навіть, просто не до порівняння.
♪ [грає на торбані меланхолійну музику] ♪
Я закінчив американський університет
по фортепіано як виконавець.
І в консерваторії трошки вчився. Небагато.
А потім десять років вчився у Кобзарському Цеху.
Зараз продовжую навчання
з гуртом «Древо» як майстер.
Здається, що я все знаю і вмію, так?
[сміється]
Але важко сказати, що я професіонал.
♪ Похвалу принесу слаткому Ісусу ♪
♪ Бо то й моя слава і вся єсть похвала. ♪
♪ Ісусе прекрасний. ♪
Усвідомив, що я є українець,
бо мама і бабуся — українки.
Тато – американець.
Він європеєць: ірландський німець.
[Марія Фединська
Дружина Юрка, музикантка, місцева активістка]
Але я любив цю мову, просив бабусю:
«Навчи мене, я хочу знати [українську] мову».
І я так зацікавився, дійсно, що там
відбувається в Україні, мушу знати!
Можливо, щось є для мене?
Як українці до мене ставитимуться?
Бабуся не має гарних зв'язків з Україною.
Вона пережила Другу Світову,
коли їй було 17 років. Багато бачила.
Їй навіть часом соромно зізнатися,
що вона українка.
♪ Вишніх создателю, земних скупителю, ♪
♪ Не забуди мене, не погуби мене. ♪
♪ Ісусе прекрасний. ♪
Питають мене, чому ми обрали Крячківку?
Не тільки через гурт «Древо».
І через дешеві землі, і можливість майструвати,
і спокій.
Усякі критерії сказали: «Іди туди!»
Я без сумнівів приїхав і не жалкую.
Я маю велике натхнення
і розумію, що є потреба у тому, щоб я тут був.
Щоб я брав участь у тому,
як держава і нація створюється.
Я люблю це!
♪ [співають українську народну пісню
«Ісусе прекрасний»] ♪
♪ Ісусе прекрасний. ♪
♪ Прийми се малоє моленіє моє ♪
♪ І скоро потщися мною умилися. ♪
♪ Ісусе прекрасний. ♪
Я хочу робити серйозний етнопроєкт не тільки
з бабусями [з «Древа»], але і з ними також.
[Гурт «Древо»
Юрко та Марія — наймолодші учасники гурту]
Ми робитимемо щось цікаве.
Це не буде зразковий етно-проєкт.
Буде багато авангарду, вільної імпровізації.
Але як майстер – теж.
Я бачу, що...
Я не знаю, наскільки я буду професійним,
але можу стати одним з найкращих.
І це не багато говорить про мене.
Це говорить про поганий рівень
майстрування цих інструментів.
Не дозволяли майструвати
в часи Радянського Союзу такі речі.
І зараз важко.
Але якщо є потреба, добре,
я забезпечуватиму її.
♪ Останнюю мольбу Тобі приношаю ♪
♪ І смиренним серцем до Тебе взиваю. ♪
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтаж
Марія Теребус]
[Музика
Юрко Фединський]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]